اعلانات السلطه الصينيه فرده اغلاق عام في
مدينه الشينغ شو وصل البلاد في سبب تفشي
فيروس كورونا ويشمل الاغلاق المناطق
الحضريه الرئيسيه لمده خمسه ايام في
الفتره من الخامس والعشرين حتى التاسعه
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري الاعلان عن
القيود الجديده بعد خروج مئات العمال في
مصنع فوكس
ايفون بالمدينه احتجاجا على عدم دفع
اجورهم ورفض لاجراءات الاغلاق فقط تداولت
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الصينيه مقاطع
فيديو تظهر تدافع العمال واشتباكه مع
عناصر الامن في محاوله لمغادره المصنع
[موسيقى]
معنى من بيجين مراسله الجزيره شيماء جوي
شيماء اذا كيف يبدا الوضع الان في هذه
المدينه وكيف يتعامل الناس مع فرد هذا
الاغلاق
صباح الخير سهام اذا هي موجه جديده ليس
فقط في مدينه جنتو وسط الصين في عموم مدن
الصين حتى هنا في العاصمه الصينيه بيجين
الصين منذ ثلاث سنوات الى حد الان ومنذ
ظهور الفيروس لم تفتح حدودها على الاطلاق
امام السياح او الرحلات العاديه ما زالت
الى الان تطبق القيود قيود السفر
والاجراءات الصارمه التي تنص على اغلاق
مدن باكملها في حال ظهور فايروس فيها في
مدينه جنشو تحديدا التي تلقب هنا في الصين
بايفون سيتي او مدينه الايفون كونها تضم
اضخم مصانع صناعه هواتف ايفون التي يتم
تصديرها الى جميع انحاء العالم سيتم اغلاق
ثماني مناطق حضاريه رئيسيه اا ليست منطا
المنطقه التي تضم مصنع فوكس ضمن هذه
المناطق الثمانيه لكن المنطقه التي يقع
فيها المصنعيه من المناطق المصنفه حسب
السلطات الصينيه من تقع عاليه الخطوره
والعمال داخل مصنع فوكس اي يعانون من ظروف
صعبه جدا حيث ان هؤلاء العمال راينا مقاطع
فيديو لهم خلال الشهر الماضي تم تسريبه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه الصينيه
لبعض العمال الذين كانوا في جنح الظلام
يحاولون الهروب او القفز من سور المصنع
وذلك لان المصنع وعدد كبير من المصانع في
الصين المهمه ليس فقط داخل الصين بل
عالميا تطبق سياسه الحلقه المغلقه هذه هي
السياسه تنص على اغلاق المصنع على عدد
معين من العمال الذين يجب ان يبقوا همم في
خطوط الانتاج للعمل نهارا والنوم ليلا
داخل المصنع المشكله هنا سهام ان ليس
هنالك سقفا زمنيا محددا لبقاء هؤلاء
العمال داخل الحلقه المغلقه او داخل خطوط
الانتاج وهذا ما سبب احتجاجات من عدد كبير
من العمال ارتفع عددهم خلال اليوم الماضي
في مقاطع فيديو كثيره تداولتها مواقع
التواصل
الصينيه تظهر اشتباكات بينهم وبين عدد
كبير من عناصر الامن الذين كانوا يرتدون
السترات البيضاء المخصصه للمستشفيات هنالك
ما خوف من تفشي الفيروس داخل هذه المصانع
خاصه وان السلطات الصينيه اا تحاول انقاذ
الاقتصاد الصيني وانقاذ المصانع الصينيه
من تبيعات فيروس كورونا التي ترزح تحتها
منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات همم اذا سهام هي موجه
جديده داخل الصين وترتفع حاله الاصابه
بشكل يومي تقريبا 996 حاله جديده خلال
اليوم الماضي تحديدا في مدينتي
الجزيره الجزيره